PROFESSOR: Directed
acyclic graphs
are a special class of graphs
that really have and warrant
a theory of their own.
Of course, "directed acyclic
graphs" is lot of syllables,
so they're called
"DAGs" for short.
OK.
So here's why they
come up all the time.
Let's look at a diagram
that may be familiar to you.
This shows the
prerequisite structure
of required courses in the
6-3 program of MIT Electrical
Engineering and Computer
Science department.
There are similar charts for
the other sub-majors of EECS
and in other
departments as well.
So what does it mean?
Well, let's look at this vertex
corresponding to the first term
calculus class 18.01.
And there's an edge
that points to 6.042.
And that's because, if
you look at the catalogue,
6.042 lists 18.01
as a prerequisite.
If you look at the algorithms--
introductory algorithms--
class 6.006, you'll find,
if you look in the catalog,
that it has listed two
prerequisites, 6.042 and 6.01.
And the fact that
they're explicitly
listed in the catalog
as prerequisites
is why there's an arrow
from 6.01 to 6.006
and from 6.042 to 6.006.
Now when you're
planning on when you
want to take 6.006, of course,
you have to attend to not just
the fact that you have to take
6.042 first and 6.01 first,
but you've got to
take the prerequisites
of those prerequisites first.
So you really have to take
18.01 before you can take 6.006.
And you need to take 8.02
before you can take 6.006.
There are corequisites here.
Let's just ignore
those and pretend
that they were prerequisites,
because they're
another kind of arrow
that needn't distract us.
OK.
So that's what this
diagram is telling us.
And this is a DAG.
It's simply a bunch of
vertices, the course
labels in rectangular
boxes, and directed arrows
showing catalog listings.
And what I said was that when
you're planning your course
work, you're really interested
in the indirect prerequisites.
So "one class, u, is an
indirect prerequisite
of another class, v"
means that there's
a sequence of prerequisites
starting from u
and going to v. It means that
you really have to have taken u
some time before you took v. And
that's a crucial fact and thing
that you need to take account
of when you're planning a course
schedule.
So in terms of graph
digraph language,
"u is an indirect
prerequisite of v"
just means that there's a
positive length walk that goes
from u to v in the digraph.
In this case, we're talking
about the 6-3 digraph
of prerequisites.
So "there's a positive length
walk from 18.01 to 6.006"
means that you really
have to have taken 18.01
before you take 6.006.
And of course,
we're talking, then,
about the positive length walk
relation D plus of the digraph
D. If D is the digraph shown
in the prerequisite chart--
direct prerequisite chart--
then we're interested in D plus.
And u D plus v just means
there's a positive length
walk-- that's what the plus
is for-- going from to u to v.
Now what happens if
you have a closed walk?
Well, a closed walk is a
walk that starts and ends
at the same vertex.
And we can ask this
question-- suppose
there was a closed walk
that started at 6.042
and ended at 6.042.
How long does it take
to graduate then?
Well, it takes a long time.
Because you can't take 6.042
until you've taken 6.042
and you're never going
to be able to take it.
That's a bad thing.
We definitely don't want
the prerequisite structure
of courses in a department
to have a closed
walk of positive length.
And in fact, there's a
faculty committee that
checks for this kind of thing.
Bugs like this
occasionally creep
in when some busy curricular
office of a department
is planning a complicated
program with dozens, if not 100
courses.
And the Committee
on Curricula's job
is to check for
that kind of thing.
There's a whole
staff that does it.
I used to be the chair
of that committee.
And we did spend a lot of time
with proposals from departments
and making sure that those
proposed course requirements
satisfied faculty rules.
OK.
So a special case of a
closed walk is a cycle.
A cycle is a walk who's only
repeat vertex is its start
and end.
Let me remark, because we keep
talking about positive length
cycles, that a single vertex all
by itself is a length-0 cycle.
So you're never going to be able
to get rid of length-0 cycles,
because they're the
same as vertices.
But positive length cycles,
you can hope to ensure
are not there.
So if you're going to
represent a cycle as a path,
you'd show the sequence of
vertices and edges, v0, v1, v2,
where the understanding is that
all of the vertices from v0 up
to v n minus 1 are
different-- that's
what makes it a cycle-- except
that the last vertex, v0, is
a repeat of the first one.
That's the one repeat
that's allowed in a cycle.
So it's natural to
draw it in a circle
like this where you start at
v0, you follow the edges around
from v1 to v i plus 1 all
the way back around to v0.
And that's kind of what a
cycle is going to look like.
So we have a very
straightforward lemma
about cycles and
closed walks, namely
that the shortest
positive length closed
walk from a vertex to
itself-- "it's closed"
means it starts and ends
at v-- is a positive length
cycle starting and ending at v.
And the reasoning and proof is
basically the same proof
that said that the shortest
walk between one
place and another
is a path from one
place to the other.
The logic is that if I have
a closed walk from v to v
and there was a repeat
in it other than at v,
I could clip out the piece of
the walk between the repeat
occurrences and I'd
get a shorter walk.
So the shortest closed walk
can't have any repeats.
It's got to be a
positive length cycle.
So a directed acyclic
graph now is defined simply
as a digraph that has no
positive length cycles.
It's acyclic, no
And of course, we
can equally well
define it, since cycles
are a special case
of closed walks and closed
walks of positive length
imply cycles, as a digraph that
has no positive length closed
walk.
Some examples of DAGs
that come up-- well,
the prerequisite graph
is going to be one.
And in general, any kind of
set of constraints on tasks,
which ones you have to do
before you do other ones,
is going to be defining
a DAG structure.
One that you might
not have thought of
is, the successor
function defines
a relation on the integers,
say, going from n to n plus 1.
So I'm going to have an
arrow that goes directly
from n to n plus 1.
And what's the walk relation
then, the positive length walk
relation, in this graph?
Well, there's a positive
length walk from n
to m precisely when
n is less than m.
So the successor DAG,
it's paths represent
the less than relation.
And of course, less than,
it doesn't have any cycles.
Because if a is
less than b, you're
never going to get around
from b back to something
that's less than
it, like back to a.
So there can't be any
cycles in the successor DAG.
And that's why it is a DAG.
Another similar one is
the proper subset relation
between sets.
So here I'm going to draw
an arrow from this set
to that set if this set
is contained in that set
but they're not equal.
So  is a subset
of , but {a, b,
d} has this extra element, d.
So the left-hand set is a proper
subset of the right-hand set.
And I'm going to
draw an arrow there.
And by the same
reasoning, there can't
be any cycles in this graph--
a positive length cycle--
because if there
was, it would mean
that the set had to be a
proper subset of itself, which
doesn't happen.
So this would be another
basic example of a DAG.
And I hope you begin to
see, from these examples,
why DAGs are really
all-pervasive
in mathematics
and in other areas
and why they merit attention.
So when we're looking
at a DAG though,
we're basically usually
interested in just the walk
relation of the DAG.
So if we're only interested in
the walk relation of the DAG,
then it would be
typically the case
that many different
DAGs are going
to have the same walk relation.
And it's natural to ask,
what's the most economical one.
Is there a minimum,
say, DAG that
defines a given walk relation?
So let's look at this example.
Here's a simple DAG.
And you can check that
there are no cycles in it.
What's the smallest DAG with
the same relation as this one?
And the way I can
get it is by going
through the edges one
at a time and asking
whether I can get
rid of the edge
because it's not
contributing anything.
So look here.
There's a path from a to
e that goes through b.
Well, that tells me that having
this direct edge from a to e
is not contributing anything
in terms of connectedness.
And that means I
could get rid of it
and I'm still going to wind
up with the same possibility
of walking from one
place to another.
Because I can always
walk from a to e
going through b instead of
going directly from a to e.
I didn't need that edge.
Another example is,
here's a walk from a
to d that goes through c.
There's no need for me to
walk directly from a to d.
As long as I'm walking, I
can take the longer walk
and get rid of the short
circuit from a to d.
Likewise, if I look at
this path from c to d to f,
I don't need that
edge from c to f.
And as a matter
of fact, now if I
look at this length 3 path
from a to c to d to f,
there's no need for me-- in
order to get from a to f,
there's no need for me--
to take the direct edge.
I can get rid of that too.
It's kind of a
redundant extra edge.
Finally, if I look at the
path from b to d to f,
I can get rid of the
direct edge from b to f.
And at this point, I'm done.
I'm left with a set of edges
called covering edges, which
have the property that the
only way to get from one vertex
to another is going to have
to be to use a covering
edge to the target for vertex.
Or more precisely, the only
way to get, say, from a to b
is going to be to use
that covering edge.
If there was any other path
that went from a elsewhere
and got back to b
without using this edge,
then it wouldn't be a
covering edge anymore.
The fact that it's
a covering edge
means that if you broke
it, there's no way
anymore to get from a to b.
So that's the definition
of covering edges
and you'll do a class problem
about them, more precisely,
in a minute.
So the other edges are unneeded
to define the walk relation.
And all we need to keep
are the covering relations
to get the minimum
representation of the walk
relation in terms of a DAG.